We're about to take a
nice 15 day cruise.
We were assured that it
was not a problem.
This thing was spreading
through the boat.
Fourteen days in a
room that's four by three.
The Diamond Princess
was ground zero.
The U.S. officials debate
whether to bring
the Americans back.
You need to get us off this ship
before we all get sick and die.
It's very intense.
And they said, "Okay, just
people who don't have Covid."
"How are you feeling?"
They didn't know
who had the Covid.
That was the
medical examination.
Our team went on board.
They started to load all America
for transport to the airport.
On the way to the airplane,
test results
would come back positive.
Pandemonium ensues.
The president is just furious.
Our numbers are going to go up.
They didn't know how to handle
a single cruise ship.
They can't get that right.
How are they going
to get the rest of this right?
Carnival knew that
there was a pandemic.
To our horror,
we realized there were many more
cruise ships out there.
Why did the cruise
ships keep sailing?